so let's start with sensor in the blood
what what what is that is this is this I
mean this is not the Brill you swallow
how do you get out of your own turn to
the blood well this is taking the
wearable sensor phase that we're in
right now to a kind of uber level of
being able to have a window into bodies
medical essence because so much is going
on in the blood and so if you can just
inject in a vein in the arm a sensor
that's about 90 microns right now we're
working with Cal Tech on their
nanosensor group it will then lodge in a
finger and then basically that can talk
continuously powered by the blood itself
to a smartphone okay powered by the
blood itself Marie what is that like a
hydroelectric dam in your bloodstream or
got it that's it it's really I couldn't
make it you could call it that it sounds
pretty good to me it's a power it's a
the power of the blood itself is
basically adequate for something that
small to provide a power source so and
this this sensor 90 microns that there's
not a risk of that that getting into the
heart and causing a blockage or
something no no it gets down to a kind
of water should capillary bed area so it
really can't go much further than that
how do you make sure that that happens
well we're doing animal testing first
but you know that they've already been
some work along those lines Stanford
also has done a microchip floating in
the blood that has to go into all them a
half so you know I think we're moving in
that direction that's a bit futuristic
it's going to be at least a few years
before we can really get that enabled in
patients but I think it's exciting
because then you could follow free
circulating DNA continuously for someone
who's had cancer or is at high risk you
can follow antibodies and the immune
system to be able to predict an immune
attack so all kinds of things by once
you have that type of surveillance so
what is the got to understand that so
what is the sensor how does the sensor
that sensor is able to mean a genetic
sequencing machine now is is huge but
this you're talking about it its sensor
that's that tiny that
how can can be parsing genetic code well
that's basically an outgrowth of this
digitizing human being because if you
can get a genomic signature it could be
DNA or RNA it could be an antibody you
can couple a sensor today to a specific
signal and that a key so it's
recognizing a pattern rather than rather
than decoding the whole thing yes
exactly